demonic a new horror film set in a
digital simulation used a new technology
called volumetric capture to create its
video game inspired look 250 cameras is
compressed into one 3d object this is
neil blomkow the director of elysium
chappie and the groundbreaking district
9. all of the science fiction films that
i've done before have maybe a tinge of
horror to them and this horror film has
a tinge of science fiction to it let's
walk through neil's process of rolling
250 cameras all at once to create
demonic's simulated world
so we travel into the mind of a person
who's in a coma and this experimental
technology lets them get out of their
body which they don't have control over
into a virtual environment why are you
here it might feel like a video game but
in reality it's a specific location in
british columbia in fact everything you
see here was captured from real life
people and places and digitized using
the techniques of photogrammetry and
volumetric capture here are the steps in
bringing the simulation to life google
earth is a good way to think of
photogrametry if you look at cities in
google earth in 3d it's the exact same
process those are just planes that are
flying over cities and taking tens of
thousands of photos if you imagine
walking around a house and taking 100
photos around the house and then you
would use drones to get things like what
the roof surfaces would look like and
then you would do a tour through the
inside of the house using handheld still
you know still shots i mean we were just
using canon mark threes if you give all
of those photos which are all still
images to a photogrammetry piece of
software it'll pull out a
three-dimensional house its fidelity is
a little bit low so blades of grass and
trees and stuff would be more like blobs
but it's still pretty good you can see
the tree on the left is left at a
resolution level that i wanted to leave
it at which makes it look very computer
generated so now you have a 3d object
that you can look at from any angle
sitting on a computer monitor although
photogrammetry has been around a while
volumetric capture hasn't especially not
in filmmaking volumetric capture is the
idea of grabbing three-dimensional
holographic video instead of
two-dimensional video of a performance
of actors at 24 times a second so it's
essentially a motion version of
photogrammetry so you're not locked into
a single angle you have like a
three-dimensional stage play of their
performance so in the case of demonic if
we have carly and natalie in the same
room acting with one another if you were
to pause any frame in there you could
move around them in three dimensions
because any individual one frame is a
frozen three-dimensional piece of
geometry filming in volumetric capture
is very taxing it's a highly synthetic
environment that is not great for actors
i mean it's essentially a scaffold cage
of cameras that are around them we had
250 cameras and you want those 250
cameras to be incredibly close to them
and then when you get to the front door
we would wheel in a plywood door that
obscured her as little as possible so it
would just look like a skeleton of a
door and that would give her something
to push open if she goes upstairs we'd
bring in plywood stairs that she would
go up instead of using vfx to lift up
the mother in this demonic possession
idea of just being levitated off the
ground you would normally use a bunch of
computers to do that but we actually
just use traditional stunt rigging with
wires to lift her out of the volumetric
capture environment if you imagine a
video game character that you can turn
around and look at from any angle that
is basically what you end up with one
issue the production team ran into was
wrangling all the data shooting in
volumetric capture yielded about 12
terabytes per day my brother and i had
to bring in 24 computers that we owned
on the back of a pickup truck to be able
to help get the data off and then they
would spend an additional 12 hours
getting that data off of the cameras and
clearing them for the next morning and
sort of by 7am being done with the day
before once the footage is finally
ingested computers go to work crunching
all the camera angles into a
three-dimensional piece of geometry the
first thing that you actually get is a
point cloud and when you zoom back from
it you can see it very clearly when you
zoom into it all of the points become
separate like they're floating atoms
it's anywhere between an hour to several
hours to compute one frame you're doing
you know thousands of frames it just it
took months in fact vfx artists with the
help of unity a game engine used to make
games like pokemon go monument valley
and cuphead had to create a custom
workflow with enhanced processors in
order to be able to render the enormous
volumetric data sets into virtual
reality where the shots were then filmed
you're basically dragging a
three-dimensional actor and placing them
on the floor of your building that
you've gathered also using
photogrammetry so now it's like a video
game now you can look at it from any
angle and you can light it any way that
you want and you can film it any way you
want you take that virtual camera
existing in the scene on a computer and
you tell it that any motion that comes
from this real handheld object in the
real world with the monitor on it which
has motion capture points on it those
motion capture points when the camera
operator moves them you tell the virtual
camera in your scene to reference these
motion capture points and move based on
what the camera operator is doing so as
he pans right your virtual camera will
exactly mimic what he's doing and then
you take the video feed coming from the
virtual camera and you pipe it to the
monitor that he's looking through so
he's effectively now inside the computer
looking at the scene and so he can then
walk around and frame shots there seems
to be plenty of interlacing between the
worlds of filmmaking and game design
will the two disciplines merge in the
future it seems to me where video game
technology will go is is in a direction
of more and more photo realism on every
level like lighting character physics
and particle simulations so it becomes
an immersive world for the person
playing the game the idea of narrative
in future gaming or future immersive
worlds may take a back seat to allowing
the gamer to just interact in the way
that they want like a grand theft auto
kind of open world it's all about the
agency of the gamer where on the film
side or the tv side the whole point is
to be a passive audience member so
you're sitting and being told a story
which is a very different experience
film has spent 100 years refining what
it does the only way that i can see it
really changing would be something like
volumetric capture where you could sit
and watch the actors through vr you
could have conversations taking place
between actors where you're sitting at
the table with them and it may be
something that audiences find
interesting and useful and it may also
not it's hard to know where that will go
but i think i think that the revolutions
of how stories are told are basically
quite locked in though what we see now i
think will be will be there for quite a
few years
[Music]